NARRATOR: Mere
feet from the face
of an imposing
mountain peak, Morgan
is adrift without power--
NARRATOR: --attempting one of
the most dangerous emergency
maneuvers in a pilot's arsenal.
NARRATOR: The box canyon
turn is a sharp, 180 degree
about face that can
mean the difference
between life and death.
NARRATOR: But to turn
on a dime, the pilot
cuts the engine mid-flight--
NARRATOR: --putting the plane
at the mercy of the winter winds
and the pilot's skill.
MORGAN: Oh, it's amazing,
actually, how well that worked
and how tight of a turn we made.
You could be in a
pretty narrow spot,
and if you commit to this turn,
you could get out of there.
NARRATOR: In an extreme
emergency at this altitude,
the only option may be to touch
down on a mountain ridge--
NARRATOR: --the only flat
surface for miles around.
But landing here
is a last resort,
because the conditions
are impossible to judge
from the air.
MORGAN: The ski could
strike an obscure rock
and, obviously, you
could slide off the edge.
MORGAN: You're already--
got a little adrenalin
going, just landing in general.
When you're landing on a ridge,
that's a whole different game.
MORGAN: There was a little bit
of a cross wind coming over,
and then the skis
just started to drift
to the right and
we we're starting
to slide off the other side.
NARRATOR: It's a hard
lesson in what it takes
to become an expert pilot
in the most extreme flying
conditions on Earth.
MORGAN: You know, it could
have been pretty bad.
Luckily, Arctic
took the airplane,
got us off the ground.
It was pretty
humbling, you know.
That's why you have an
instructor in the plane,
to help recover when
you do make a mistake.
NARRATOR: But close
call or not, Morgan
can't quit until he's made the
mountain landing on his own.
MORGAN: After that
flawed landing there,
I'm a little nervous.
That's what I'm here
for, so I'm going
to try to suck it up and line
up in a better direction,
and try to figure
out what the wind's
doing to land into the wind.
[ski hitting mountain]
MORGAN: The bridge
landing was pretty tricky,
but it's good to have
done it now in case
I absolutely have to sometime.
NARRATOR: It'll take years for
Morgan to master every skill,
but for now, he's
ready to fly solo.
MORGAN: We put a lot of
time and money and effort
into getting the necessary
skills to fly out here.
I still have a lot
to learn, but now I
am ready to give it a shot.
It's going to be
pretty exciting.